assez noir
par euh
qui
dit les trente secondes d'un ouais ben
tu attends d'
accord
qu'en est-il euh un 30 secondes d'un test
un peu lent obturateur
ouais
ouais c'est mieux
oh
c'est
euh
tout
sur
euh
maintenant
c'est
bien
aussi avec le penche un peu  un peu plus
grand ouvert d'
accord en
tournant à gauche
de la pluie sur la gauche ici
euh pouvons-nous faire à propos de cette
distance focale légèrement plus longue
c'est mieux de cette façon vers l'arrière
qu'en est-il de faire une prise de vue latérale ouais ouais
eh bien nous allons juste faire une bonne course à ce coup à l'
envers  pendant que l'objectif est
propre, d'accord,
on pourrait jouer à gauche
du fil pour que je puisse tirer deux à
trois
heures de profil
merci
c'est ce que nous faisons
encore un instant,
allez à droite comme ça mais c'est probablement  trop
flou
oh ça va être très facile d'
accord arrête d'enregistrer
euh on y
va sur le plus petit train de réparation d'
accord mec d'
accord oh je viens d'arrêter
maintenant je viens de le mettre ouais d'accord
tu as un parapluie
vitesse de croisière
c'est le coup de retour à la maison
ouais beaucoup  de  la pluie passe par le coup
voyons si
dehors
ouais
oublie ça d'
accord
descends juste à côté du camion jaune
si nous voulons faire quelque chose d'accord
tu veux faire ça ouais c'est vrai d'
accord
chatouilles
ralentis et descends bas quand nous passons
devant ceux-ci  les gars
descendent d'accord alors allons-y oh
ce gars là
hey
euh
euh d'
accord
continue
arrête
ça ne marche pas
il est sorti d'accord
je vais aider l'
aire d'atterrissage juste ici
toi